c'est presse a perdu deux récompenses
navy et que dalle
si le mec s'est fait chier venir jusque
là on va lui prendre un pack à doser
regarde voilà il est la halle du gouffre
c'est pas sérieux
je fais part et j'ai couru pour la
retrouver votre de 12 kw à des jeunes la
récompense comment s'organise
je pensais à 100 euros 155 rencontres
ont alors 150 avec un contrôle sans
saveur goudron paroisse si monsieur
s'est tué 92 me fie à un bon plaisir
nous avons aussi quand on peut rendre
service mais c'est pas nouveau m'a fait
ça ça passe ça s'est passé comment je
peux peut-être vous aider à le retrouver
sofiane michel pourra pas tant d'argent
quand j'ai pas de loup de mafieux entre
les mains c'est clair ça en vient aux
[ __ ] de nuit s'il qu'est ce qu'elle
est bonne c'est ma femme 1 1 voilà on
l'a retrouvé le nounours ce crime à
milan non ma mine on bosse ce doudou
c'est pas fini l'a bien par marc pigeon
essayons alors pourtant il ya la place
c'est à dire
vas-y tu as deux doigts tu sais ce que
c'est qu'un doudou et une police qui
sont mauvais c'est un objet
transitionnel qui permet à un enfant en
situation de stress affectif de se
sentir en sécurité on est sur wii qui
fait qu'ils appuient le peut pas
s'endormir sans son doudou non sans plus
marron et je vais donner à ma petite
fille
nous sommes dans la recherche a cédé 4
sélections non non pas du tout
non mais ça va pas elle est longue cette
journée
notre guide veut juste récupérer le
doudou de ma fille moi j'aimerais vivre
en colocation avec jésus christ pas
possible on a tous nos rêves combien
en touche au but seulement nausée que je
vais toucher au but c'est une obsession
chez toi ça s'appelle être pauvre